so thank you for the introduction I'm
Keith Krause I am a manager in the
infrastructure department of Nvidia and
kind of specifically I'm on the team
that works on Rapids and I'm gonna go to
kind of detail out what Rapids is and
kind of how we've been working working
on Rapids and building Rapids but at a
very high level Rapids is an open-source
collection of libraries designed to
accelerate data science by running the
entire data science pipeline using GPUs
so kind of to dive in we're a day and
age where basically every every
Enterprise has become an has become this
data-driven enterprise and in doing so
we're just generating more and more data
and having to analyze more and more and
more data and basically we're at the
point where we're starting to kind of
look at and hit exascale
and kind of the way the way people have
traditionally looked at and tried to
tackle this problem is in the Big Data
space and so kind of a decade ago it
started with Hadoop and so you had this
parrot you had this paradigm of you know
massively scale out and that every
single kind of step in your pipeline you
would read data from disk and then write
data from disk and it was it was really
expensive because all of this reading
and writing data is really expensive and
so then SPARC came around and sparks
main claim to fame was that you know you
read once and then everything is in
memory in Sparks kind of in-memory data
format as well as then everything is
built on top of this single data format
so I don't need to go through any
additional copy and conversions I don't
need to write out to disk as well as
just more efficient kind of computation
in general but today we're in this we've
hit this kind of the same problem that
we previously hit with Hadoop in that
we're starting to see bottlenecks where
we don't want to see them and so kind of
what this is what this picture here is
showing is that this is a really simple
workload of basically just you know
group group by a column and get me
essentially just the count of that
column and you can see here this is like
a 20 core CPU we're actually just
completely pegging the CPU
we're getting compute bottlenecked
before we actually get memory throughput
bottlenecked
and what's crazy about this is this is
after the data has already been kind of
parsed or decompressed into memory and
that is typically a super expensive
process where you'll also bottleneck at
compute as well and then if we kind of
extend that query into more complex
workloads and then also look into things
like machine learning then the the
compute battlenet just becomes even
worse and so you know how how can we do
better what can we do to kind of relieve
some of these bottlenecks and improve
our data science performance we we need
to focus on the full data science
workflow so kind of from beginning to
end everything from data loading
including kind of decompression file
format parsing to then your data
transformation so things like ETL
feature engineering into then running
your analytics doing traditional machine
learning graph analytics into things
like deep learning as well basically we
need to we can't just pick and choose
pieces to accelerate we need to
accelerate the entire pipeline otherwise
we hit on dollas law which basically
says that the slowest piece in the
pipeline is going to basically dominate
your pipeline and you won't see benefits
because of it and so you know NVIDIA
NVIDIA has built GPUs and built
accelerated processing using GPS for a
long time but the stance was always you
know just just write CUDA kernels
program in like C C++ and builds
implementations yourself and we know in
the data science the data engineering
communities that's a non-starter and so
we need to we need to kind of work in
this Python PI data ecosystem to provide
basically as close to a drop-in
replacement for existing tools so that
there isn't this kind of friction in
adopting new tools for data scientists
and data engineers but at the same time
we want to keep the performance that GPU
acceleration offers you so that you can
get these kind of rapid results and do
more iterations on what you're trying to
solve and so GPUs are fast but people
have talked about that there's too many
adoption barriers for GPUs
you know there's too much data movement
to get data into GPUs to get data out of
GPUs how do I move data between nodes
with GPUs there's too many makeshift
data formats where if I have data format
a and someone else's data format B how
do we work together I'm gonna have to do
some nasty conversion on the CPU and
then I'm gonna lose all my performance
as I said writing CUDA C C++ it's a
non-starter
you can't expect your data scientist or
data engineers to really do that and
there was there wasn't this high level
API to use for data engineering data
science in general and so kind of this
is this is kind of the classic GPU
acceleration problem where I have two
applications that both use GPUs today
and they both offer great accelerations
for their their own kind of purpose but
the problem is in order to go from an
application a to application B I have
this kind of really gross data pipeline
where basically I load data into my GPU
but then to get it to the other
application I need to move it back into
the CPU to do some kind of conversion to
then move it back to the GPU and what
almost looks like the original data
format for the second application to
consume and the problem is that those
copy and converts that happened there in
red are 99% of the time way more
expensive than anything you're doing an
application a or application B and so
you lose any semblance of acceleration
that you hope to achieve and so kind of
one of the reasons kind of Rapids is
here today is because of this question
of you know what if we could go between
these different stages in the data
science pipeline and keep data on the
GPU and not have to leave the GPU and do
all of those gross copying conversions
what kind of acceleration could we see
how would this change the data science
process and so from that question we
kind of we looked into the Big Data
community and we we kind of took some
learnings from the Apache aero project
and so the Apache era project is it's a
library for a in-memory columnar data
format and basically the claim to fame
of it is that kind of the big data
ecosystem is standardizing around it
and it's allowing interoperability
between a bunch of these different big
data projects and so things like spark
park a kudu pandas etc are all
standardizing around this one memory
format so I don't need to do these
really kind of expensive and gross
conversions in order to get data from
one life from one technology to another
technology and kind of in addition to
that it provides really efficient on
wire format so I don't need to spend a
ton of compute in a ton of time
constantly serializing and deserializing
my data in order to move it between
processes and so kind of building a
building on top of the idea of Apache
Aero we we released this open-source
suite of software called Rapids and kind
of at its core Rapids Rapids is designed
to build bridges in the GPU community
that we want basically people to be able
to write these modular data pipelines
and experience GPU acceleration at every
step and so we have we have three main
libraries today there's qu TF which is
it kind of looks and feels like pandas
but you get GPU accelerated performance
underneath you have qu ml which looks
and feels like scikit-learn but you get
GPU accelerated performance we will be
releasing ku graph hopefully in the next
month or two which will kind of it'll
probably have a network X like API it's
still being kind of the API still being
defined somewhat and then we're also
kind of providing tie-in to things like
your deep learning frameworks and then
GPU accelerated visualization engines as
well and so kind of we move we move from
this space of you know warehouse Park
accelerated Hadoop but now spark is
getting bottlenecked by the amount of
compute that you have we move into this
new space where you do you kind of pay a
one-time cost to get data into the GPUs
and then everything that you want to do
there is accelerated and you don't have
to pay the cost to move between those
different pipe those different steps in
the GPU data science pipeline
and so kind of what what is Rapids how
did we build Rapids and kind of how we
built Rapids is we wanted to learn what
the data science community needed and
build it based on their needs and based
on kind of the feedback that the data
science community gave and so
essentially what we did is we took both
a top-down and a bottom-up approach in
that you know Nvidia and vidi has built
GPUs we built CUDA to enable some of the
world's most demanding workloads and so
we took the idea you know Rapids we can
get huge acceleration if we build
libraries on top of CUDA to get huge
performance benefits but at the same
time we need to build high level easy to
use libraries in order for data
scientists and data engineers to benefit
them and then figure out how to tie them
down into these this optimized CUDA
layer and so it was really both a kind
of hard guidelines in that we need the
performance of CUDA underneath but we
need the usability of kind of high level
languages like Python and the PI data
ecosystem on top and then kind of
following those principles use that to
kind of build build libraries builds
scalable systems and algorithms and then
continue to iterate on top of that and
so kind of the software of Rapids is
available today so you can go to github
both ku DF and ku ml are out there open
source ku graph should be coming in the
next month or two as well we
additionally we provide Conda install we
are working on pip install currently it
should hopefully be coming in the next
couple of months and then we also
provide containers both on docker hub
and NGC if you just want to pull
container and that includes that
includes some sample pipelines and
including a multi-gpu
a multi-gpu kind of mortgage workflow
that we ran that uses there's a
combination of multi-gpu kind of ETL
feature engineering into then running a
multi-gpu XG boost classification to
build a model and so kind of let's talk
about COO ml and COO graph first and so
kind of COO ml and COO graph are what
we're thinking of is like the AI
libraries of rapids where basically the
idea is that
want to accelerate these machine
learning graph analytics and time series
type algorithms to take advantage of the
parallel compute capabilities of GPUs
and so we're targeting kind of we're
targeting everything that's in
scikit-learn Network X and then kind of
taking that further in certain cases
like for example graph analytics Network
X is kind of limited in both the size
that it can do and the complexity of the
algorithms that it can do we can do
quite a lot more using GPUs and so we're
going to try to provide that with the
same high level easy-to-use api's as
well but kind of everything from
decision trees linear logistic
regressions clustering like k-means DB
scan maybe you map in the future as well
as things like common filtering and then
things in graph analytic space kind of
your typical PageRank breadth-first
search triangle counting as well as some
other things like lu vein modularity as
well and so kind of what what what can
you expect to see in moving your
workloads to the GPU and so this is kind
of an end-to-end pipeline working with a
couple hundred gigabytes of CSV data and
basically from moving from moving the
pipeline to the GPU you can see here on
a single box and granted it's it's a big
expensive box with 16 V 100 GPUs we can
significantly significantly outperform a
hundred nodes of SPARC to the point
where dollar-for-dollar you're doing
significantly better performance wise
and this includes everything from
loading the data loading the data from
disk in CSV format into then doing all
of your kind of data cleansing data
transformations feature engineering into
then training and actually boost model
on it as well and there's actually still
a little bit of inefficiencies because
we couldn't store the entire result set
of the ETL in GPU memory all at once
where we actually had to write out to
system memory and then read it back in
before training actually boost model
otherwise we have run out of GPU memory
and we're still seeing these huge speed
ups and we're continuing to work at
addressing these inefficiencies to make
these pipelines as efficient as possible
and then kind of in addition to that
in addition to being able to run single
mode you were working this these are
early results but we're working towards
enabling you to scale out as well scale
up and so this is running across five
dgx ones
so rather than 16 GPUs in a single box
using 40 GPUs across five boxes and so
you can see here we're getting huge
benefit on kind of the ETL and data
loading time just because you can it's
embarrassingly parallel you can scale it
out more but on kind of extra boost
training side there isn't quite as much
of a benefit but we are working to
address that hopefully in the next
couple months or so and so you can see
here machine learning an extra boost in
particular is a great example where
scaling up is really really gives you a
huge benefit over scaling out in that
the algorithm just very quickly becomes
communication bound and so kind of you
can see here versus it doesn't you can
keep scaling out with CPUs but you won't
get much benefit in doing so and then
even in the GPU boxes we're seeing we're
seeing huge speed ups over the CPU side
but in going from a single box 16 GPUs
versus 5 boxes with a cheapy use each
we're not seeing that much of a speed-up
just because you get bottlenecked even
going over like 4 100 gigabyte network
interfaces that you just get
bottlenecked in the communication
between the boxes and so kind of just
some teaser benchmarks as well of some
of the other algorithms so kind of some
of the first 3t SVD PCI and DB scan
where we're seeing some really nice
benefits over scikit-learn and
especially as you increase the amount of
data the amount of features that you're
training on those increases will just
continue to grow these these are kind of
our first pass and implementation as
well and so kind of as we continue to
build out these libraries in the future
we will continue to optimize them and
improve them further and so kind of some
of some of the kind of algorithms that
are in development right now and will be
coming in the very near future so we
have k-means and k9 which should be
coming in the next few weeks common
filters collaborative filtering GLM
and random forests are all in the works
as well and should be coming in the next
month or two and then additionally we're
working on some additional time series
and clustering algorithms as well as the
Bayesian methods which are a little bit
further out in the timeline but are
coming as well and then this soca graph
gpu-accelerated graph analytics library
this will be released open source in the
next couple months and just a teaser of
kind of PageRank in the kind of speed
ups you can see you can expect to see
over Network X in the worst case we're
getting on 130 x speed up and then you
can see we're getting like a 10,000
times speed-up in certain cases so that
will be coming soon and then kind of the
initial algorithms you could expect to
see would be like PageRank breadth-first
search and triangle counting and then
things like Jaccard similarity lu vein
modularity and other algorithms would be
coming in the future
and so those those were kind of like the
machine learning graph libraries let's
talk about just the general data frame
library that allows you to do kind of
your data transformation and some
analytics as well and so one of the
questions that we get a lot in talking
about rapids is you know is GPU
accelerated ETL as GPU accelerated
analytics really needed and the answer
the answer is yes in that today data
scientists are spending like 90 plus
percent of their time in just trying to
wrangle their data and struggling with
wrangling their data as opposed to kind
of fine-tuning their models and
iterating on their models to improve
accuracy and solve the problem that
they're actually trying to solve and so
if we if we can drastically speed up
kind of the ETL data transformation data
wrangling step we can allow them to do a
lot more iterations and fine-tune their
models a lot more which basically
directly translates to better results
both for the business and for the data
scientist and kind of as a as a side
note to that we want to we want to get
rid of the caffeine addiction in the
data science world where we're tired of
someone kind of kicking off an ETL job
or training job and then being like
well this is gonna take half an hour or
an hour I will grab a cup of coffee and
then coming back oh there was some
random error all right I need to tweak
something rerun it let's go grab another
cup of coffee we want kind of this
almost instant feedback loop so that
users can work a lot more productively
as opposed to kind of almost this
fire-and-forget style of working that
they kick it off and just hope for the
best and then come back later and with
their fingers crossed and then see if it
either succeeded or failed and so kind
of the first step in enabling this is
this coup DF gpu-accelerated data frame
library and what this library does is it
uses the Apache auro data format
underneath and then provides a pendous
like API it's about 90 95 percent the
same as pandas there's a few places that
we differ mostly surrounding multi
indexing and indexing but it gives you
kind of all the things are used to of
like unary and binary operations joins
merges group buys filters as well as
doing some really cool things with
user-defined functions which I'll touch
on a little bit and accelerated file
readers as well and so kind of what
kudia looked like up until a couple
weeks ago was it was a split between
these two libraries libgdx
INF and so lib gdf was this low-level
library containing C and C++ api's and
then the actual kind of CUDA kernel
implementations of all these functions
and it also provided some low-level
functionality like being able to export
and import these GPU data frames using
CUDA inter process communication and
then things like sorting join group by
and reduction kernels pi GAF was the
Python library that provided the
pythonic interface on top of it and kind
of provided the integration into the PI
data ecosystem and so things like being
able to easily create GPU data frames
from things like numpy arrays pandas
dataframes pi ro tables as well as just
general python objects and then also
really cool is being allowing the user
to write just very naive Python
user-defined functions and then actually
just-in-time compiling those into GPU
kernels you
so that even if you don't have like a
built-in function you can still get GPU
accelerated performance for it and so
today we're just about done with a big
refactor where we're moving libgdx and
hygena for going away and there will
just be coup D F and so it is a single
repo it's already combined into a single
repository containing both the low-level
implementations and the high-level
wrappers and api's and kind of part of
the reason for doing this is that you
know when we originally were building
out PI G d/f and Lib gdf it had a very
Python centric view of the world and
even though this is PI data we we want
to DF to be language agnostic to a
certain point where if the community
wants and wants to contribute our
bindings or Giulia bindings or like even
Java bindings for example cou DF will
provide a natural place for those to
live and then also allow kind of the
same things that the Apache Aero
library is allowing in that really
efficient kind of handing off between
these different languages without the
kind of typical steep performance
penalties that you see from it and then
in addition where we originally see FF I
to bind the Python to the C layer and
we're moving to scythe on for better
integration into the PI data community
and just for better maintainability as
well and so kind of just to give you
example fortunately these are a little
bit outdated so it still references pi
GD f but just to show kind of the usage
of the library a little bit you know
it's just your Python standard Python
library import PI G d/f and then for
example to go from a panda's data frame
to a GPU data freedom it's a single line
of from pandas it's the same from numpy
rays it's the same from PI arrow tables
and it's the same to go back to those as
well it's just two pandas or two arrow
for example and then in addition to that
you have kind of like typical things
that you would do in pandas where for
example you can run a query so for
example filter the data frame where my
Inc earned column is greater than or
equal to zero and then kind of more
advanced things like writing a
user-defined function
where you can basically just very
naively define a pure Python function as
a definition and then tell it call this
apply map function and what that does is
basically element-wise in that column it
will run that Python function but it
doesn't just run that Python function
like it normally does it actually takes
that function just in time compiles it
into GPU machine code and then runs that
on the GPU and so you can write really
flexible things in just very naive
Python and get GPU accelerated
performance on it and so kind of every
everything in CUDA F is single GPU and
the way we're moving the way we're kind
of scaling up and scaling out is using a
library called Basques and so for those
for those who aren't familiar with tasks
tasks is a distributed computational
scheduler built to integrate with the
Python data science ecosystem to allow
you to scale your workloads from
anything to using all of the cores
available in your laptop to scheduling
it across all of the nodes in a super
computing cluster and kind of why why
we're using desk and what like why
Rapids uses desk to both scale up and
scale out is that desk is it's extremely
modular in that it's got essentially
different modules for scheduling the
compute handling data transferring
communications handling essentially like
out of poor memory caching and
everything like that they're all
separate modules and you can kind of
plug in your own implementations where
you want to and so for us what this
means is that we can easily run multiple
desk workers per node so we can run
essentially Kadath work or per GPU and
then it becomes the same execution and
programming model whether you want to
run across like two GPUs in your desktop
or across a thousand GPUs in your data
center and then it's basically the same
code and that we we kind of handle
everything underneath the hood for you
to be able to scale up or scale out your
application and so kind of looking at
kudi f-first
we have a library called vasco DF which
it uses the kind of efficient single GPU
primitives
we've built underneath the hood in a
MapReduce style in a MapReduce style
operation and then exposed as kind of
the same high level API for users and
then kind of some of the things that we
did if you look at das data frame which
uses pandas underneath we plugged in our
qu TF GPU accelerated primitives and
then in addition to that we we kind of
pulled out the typical task
communication paradigm where - typically
pickels objects and then sends those
pickled objects over tcp to other
workers what we did is we kind of
removed that and plugged it in plugged
in right now that instead of actually
pickling the object we generate what's
called a CUDA IPC handle which you can
think of it as essentially a pointer
that can be shared across processes and
we only ship that and so when
communicating from work at a worker
communications are essentially free
because all we're shipping is a pointer
as opposed to actually sending any data
and then as we look towards kind of
scaling out to multi node we're using
we're working with the open ucx
community and open you see X is
essentially a communication abstraction
layer that allows really efficient
communications taking advantage of any
hardware present that's what this means
is that if you have advanced hardware
like InfiniBand or 100 gig Ethernet with
rocky we can use techniques like GPU our
DMA but if you don't have them we can
easily just fallback to TCP as well and
still be way more efficient than using
kind of pickle in order to serialize
data to ship over a wire and in addition
to that is say all of your workers are
within a single node we could take
advantage of things like envy link and
PCI Express peer-to-peer communications
so that you don't need to do any
unnecessary kind of network data
movement and then kind of looking
looking at the machine learning side as
well it allows us to build these
distributed both scale up and scale out
machine learning algorithms as well in
that we can a natively integrate with
tasks + qu DF and so it allows us to
easily take in data that's already
distributed across multiple GPUs
then we can use tasks to initialize this
library called nickel which is a it's a
collective communications library and so
it basically provides provides easy to
use primitives for really efficient
things like hey I need to reduce my data
and then have a copy of that reduced
result across all my workers or for
example I need to take this this chunk
of data that only exists on one worker
and scatter that to every single worker
and so that's gives us the ability to
call these nickel primitives really
easily and then tasks also gives us the
ability to kind of synchronize all the
workers which is really needed and a lot
of these machine learning algorithms but
still kind of take advantage of all of
the GPU acceleration and hardware
advantages that are available to us and
so looking to the future what are some
of the things that kind of you can
expect from Rapids over the next couple
of months so on the cou DF GPU data
frame side we're going to and continue
to improve the performance and the
functionality across both single GPU
single node multi-gpu and multi node
multi-gpu in the next few weeks we're
going to be actually releasing a GPU
accelerated string package and so this
is going to be similar to using kind of
pandas string functions except provide
an actual native GPU implementation with
some really nice acceleration and I'll
show some early results and then we're
going to continue to build out our
accelerated data loading things so for
example today we have a semi limited CSV
reader we're going to continue to
increase the functionality and
performance that CSV Reader and then
you'll should see things like a park a
reader and an orc reader coming in the
near future as well so first thing koo
string it's going to follow it's going
to follow the pandas api for working
with like arrays of strings and you can
see here kind of some some standard
functions of like converting all the
strings in your column to lowercase
finding a substring in a string or
slicing a string based on kind of some
indexes within the string you can see
some really big speed ups and these are
all single GPU as well and then
accelerated data loading so this is
something that we when we were
first building out Rapids we didn't we
didn't think we were going to need to
tackle immediately but as we kind of
built out some data science workflows
and started to test Rapids and
applications we quickly found that data
loading was the bottleneck and so this
this chart here is from a blog from the
Apache Krell project which it's a
project out of IBM Research designed for
really efficient distributed storage
taking advantage of modern hardware and
so you can see here that kind of all of
the typical data science formats like
JSON Avro Parque ork they all get
bottlenecked in getting data into memory
by the CPU and so as we continue to
build out these GPU accelerated file
readers we should see some really nice
speed ups and see if you notice CSV
isn't even on this chart because CSV is
actually one of the least rigidly
defined formats and so it actually makes
it one of the trickiest ones where the
performance would be even less than JSON
here and so we have we have a CSV reader
out there today it follows the API of
pandas read CSV it isn't completely
full-featured yet but it's absolutely
usable and we're seeing some really big
speed benefits on it where typically
it's a greater than 10x speed up over
pandas there is a work in progress pull
requests for the park' reader out there
already it should hopefully get merged
soon and then we're going to continue to
improve upon it the orc Reader you
should see a pull request over in the
next couple weeks and then we're
starting to investigate what it would
look like to handle actual decompression
and compression on the GPU as well so
that you can essentially just ship
compressed data over to the GPU and then
we accelerate the decompression
accelerate the file format parsing and
then you can go into your actual kind of
transformation and ETL steps and then
something else we've been working we've
been working with the an account with
anaconda and
come the open source ecosystem and
helping to define and drive adoption of
what's called the python cuda array
interface and what it is it's basically
like a standard metadata for
n-dimensional
arrays on the GPU to describe their ways
their arrays sorry so kind of similar to
how numpy has a standard metadata for
describing its arrays we're trying to do
the same thing on the GPU which
basically what it'll say is here's the
memory here's the pointer to my memory
here's my size here's my data type
here are my strides here are my shape to
basically allow all of these different
GPU accelerated array libraries to
interoperate with each other without
kind of the typical performance hit of
having to copy off to a numpy array to
then copy it back to the GPU in what's
essentially the same format that it
started in and so number qu pi and pi
torch are the first libraries to adopt
this interface and kind of the current
state of things is the number library
basically allows for any anything that
exposes this CUDA array interface to
come in so what this means is that if I
define a coupe array or PI torch tensor
I can then run number just-in-time
compiled functions against those arrays
natively we're working with the PI torch
and communities to allow them to accept
cuda cuda array interfaced objects as
well so that I'll be able to go for
example from a PI torch tensor to a coop
IRA to a number device Rea and kind of
any combination thereof without any kind
of big performances and doing so and so
with that join the movement everyone can
help Rapids Rapids is open source
we're built on top of the Apache Aero
project which is open source and then
this original a lot of this work
originally started in the GPU open
analytics initiative as well and then as
the work is matured it's moved into the
rapid project where all these are
basically built around accelerating the
open source data science ecosystem so
everything from feedback documentation
polar quests anything it all helps and
additionally we were hiring an Nvidia if
you're interested to help us build the
future come and talk to me we're
basically hiring across the board as far
as like python dev ops e ICD build and
release packaging general data
engineering data science
CUDA developers and we have we have
internships for the summer as well if
you're interested so if you if you want
to help build the future of Rapids and
the gpu-accelerated
data science ecosystem please come talk
to me and with that thank you and I'll
take any questions thank you great
presentation how did you make a decision
to not go lower level and for example
and build it into numpy as a completely
abstract it for the for the user
allowing numpy to leverage which also
under under pins pandas etc and just to
make it abstract it's rather than
another library to which we never know
whether adoption will be sufficient to
the say enterprise users so so we've
actually a lot of a lot of the Apache
arrow developers or actually pandas
developers as well and we work we've
been working very closely with the
Apache arrow community we've talked to a
lot of these developers and basically in
talking with them the consensus was that
we shouldn't try to just build something
that if you use pandas today it just
works that pandas and it's an umpire
they were built like a decade ago and
they were built on kind of the state of
data science community and hardware a
decade ago and that we shouldn't
necessarily confine ourselves to what
pandas and numpy allow you to do and
then addition additional to that there's
a lot of things that you can do on the
GPU that you wouldn't even think about
doing on the CPU and so kind of by
having a separate library that looks and
feels like it but isn't the exact same
it gives us the flexibility to kind of
provide additional functionality that
wouldn't make sense to provide within
pandas or numpy today hi thank you for a
speech my question is as a data
scientist not
very familiar was Hardware part really
my preference would be easier to adopt
would be better I'm not quite sure I bet
you you definitely have have you heard
about the open a I currently launched
collaboratory which offer basically
hardware accelerator in the cloud
including not just GPU but also TPU from
for me using attributer notebook a lot
it's awesome
unbelievably easier because it's exactly
the same code you can just change the
accelerator no need to rewrite the code
so how do you think of comparing of that
project with yours what is an advantage
because I think you should have some
advantage compared with that and also
from the graph you showed us how data
get processed from CPU to GPU it seems
so complicated but why open I I make is
so easy for the for the data gap process
or the code gets adjusted to GPU thank
you sure so open AI is kind of more
focused on neural networks and deep
learning what Rapids is focused on is
kind of the steps before deep learning
and neural networks in kind of all of
the things that you still typically have
to do so from everything from loading
your data from disk or from a database
for example into then kind of all of
your data wrangling data munging feature
engineering and then kind of more
traditional machine learning graph
analytics type use cases where open ai
and some one correct me if I'm wrong is
more focused on kind of training deep
neural networks and so for the case of
deep neural net where it's the amount
the kind of the amount of operations
that you have to do is a much smaller
subset than general data science and so
for kind of for those things that
opening has targeting the teeth the TPU
for example GPU see
to use they all have implementations
where as kind of in the traditional data
science world you have GPU and CPU so
like for example to go between pandas
and 2df it's absolutely minimal code
changes the only places that we really
differ API wise are in regards to multi
indexing where people typically fight
against it as opposed to work with it
it's what we've seen in pandas so we
made the decision that you know we're
not going to support multi indexing but
in general you could almost do import
kudi f as pandas and your code will just
work and so then that makes it really
easy to switch between CPU and GPU that
being said I'm not an expert on TP use I
don't know exactly what they support and
what they don't support but my
understanding is that kind of because
this is more general-purpose parallel
computing that it doesn't necessarily
fit the TPU execution paradigm well no
it does not that still runs single
threaded on the CPU all right I think we
have to let the next group in so let's
thank Keith
[Applause]